this is a production of Cornell
University
hello everyone so this is a photo of a
rora Musgrave field and the trials are
happening so it freaka days talk I'm
gonna first talk about the social
ecological perspective how I'm thinking
about this research I'm situating myself
then I'm going to talk about three
different research projects that I have
going on the first is plant competition
within mixtures
the second is mixtures within cropping
systems and the third is cropping
systems within New York's dairy farm so
the social ecological system perspective
with a - emerge from systems level
ecology people are studying landscape
level things Everglades whole watersheds
and they realize that you in action
shape the capacities of ecosystems and
humans are in fact part of the
ecosystems and this is the thinking that
I'm going about with all this research
that we are a part of the ecosystems
they're not just linked together so as
the actual specific definition for
resilience has three different
components the first is the amount of
disturbance a system can absorb and
still remain within the same state so
this is how much you can absorb the
second is the degree to which the system
is capable of self-organization so you
might imagine if a farmer were to desire
to change a practice maybe they wouldn't
be able to because they've been there
locked in by certain regulations or the
market or they need to continue
something so they can't recreate
themselves and the third thing is the
degree to which the system can build and
increase its capacity for learning and
adoption so learning is a constantly an
important thing improving on one
the the definition or a sentence but I
really like from somewhere if I keep did
fall over and Department of Natural
Resources between ecology economics
social structures that was great
ecosystem services and when we talk
about resilience this is really abstract
term it can mean whatever you want it to
mean and so for this I think of
resilience of a farm in the face of
extreme weather events and the reason
I'm thinking about this is the Northeast
has got seen a 71 percent increase in
extreme precipitation events since 1958
this is a graph from the earth National
Climate Assessment that came out last
Friday uh and each bar is a year the
orange line is a nine year average and
so this is again extreme precipitation
events we can see that they're
increasing so although temperatures
might increase the growing season in the
Northeast which could lead to you know
longer growing season we are going to
have some really wet weather really
frequent intense rainstorms and also
short and medium-term droughts so I
think of practice of diversification as
a strategy to enhance resilience and I
just go back to the thing putting all
your eggs in one basket because
essentially this is what we're doing
with a lot of cropping systems and that
they're very simplified and we're maxing
out their productivity of them but crop
diversity as this variability and rid
and redundancy so this variability can
diversity baguettes diversity if you
have more diverse pants likely that
you're going to have more diverse
microbes or you'll have more diverse
insects and so this is pretty exciting
but it does come out of cost it isn't as
simple as all your eggs in one basket
and I want to make that clear because
because I would say that's probably the
biggest difficulty with crop
diversification as a strategy so if we
were to if I understand this as a
strategy then there's some things that
we need to figure out and so the first
question that I asked myself is how can
inter crop mixtures be optimized for by
oppressed production so how can these
and how can we improve these crop
diversification practices even more and
so I'm looking specifically at inner
crop mixtures so multiple species at the
same time the second question I asked
myself what are the effective diversity
over time and so if if they take some
time to take into effect are we doing
the right kind of experiments that would
allow us to see some of the benefits of
crop diversification and finally who's
going to use this strategy and why so
how does it fit in what is the context
so the first question how can inner crab
mixtures be optimized for a biomass
production I'm going to use cover crops
as an example for this so this
experiment that we did was on
semi-annual forges but if you were to
think of them as cover crops uh which
they could be at less than 5% of row
crop land in the United States its cover
crops so cover crops are getting a lot
of hype but if but we still have a
really limited adoption and a lot of
people have done studies as to why that
might be one of the one of the barriers
identified was this associated cost so
getting
buying extra seed having to take this
extra time so the purpose of this
experiment is to examine enter an
interest rate competition to understand
complementarity with the hypothesis that
mixtures with greater complementarity
will have greater cover crop biomass and
so for this experiment we had two
grasses and two legumes pearl millet
deviated with the MS sorghum Sudan grasp
with an S legumes word cow pew previa
did with the sea and Sun hemp
abbreviated with an H and I just want to
refer back to some previous work I've
done this came out of my Master's when
we published this paper on functional
diversity and summer annual legume inner
crops so we used the same exact same
species and we just seated a three
species mixtures using a replacement
rate design so you have a monoculture of
eight and then one third of that for a
three species mixture so one-third
one-third one-third and then it's a way
you assess of their the most common way
to assess inter crops it I would say
it's the land equivalent ratio which is
essentially the of that species their
proportion of the biomass in the inner
crop divided by the biomass of that
species in the monoculture and so if
we're seating these species each had a
third of their monoculture rates our
breakeven point 4 lambda prevalent ratio
would be 1 we plant a third of the seeds
expected third of the biomass and so we
see from the results and the
abbreviations are down here the four
three species mixtures all had land
equivalent ratio is greater than one
which is awesome right it's like fate
there's intercropping work but what does
what does that mean what is really
happening within that number so what we
did with this paper is we took
the single term the partial lar so just
one term of this model we made each a
point on a spider hi so these spider
plots have three species thus three
points and if you were to fill in this
inner strangle here that would be
one-third that would be your break-even
point and so we see that some mixtures
have le RS above one and there's mutual
over healing each species does better in
the inner prop than it would if it had
been planted separately but some of the
mixtures you see one species is really
pulling that biomass up and it comes
with the consequence suppressing these
slower growing species so the one thing
we've learned is if your intercropping
with annuals in a mixture they gotta
have a similar growth rate they're gonna
leave the gate at the same time or else
that kind of competition is gonna
continue and you won't see the benefits
of these species because they won't
appear as Bunch so practical questions
for this experiment is the the question
is what is the optimal seeding rate for
each species to maximize the biomass and
then another question is how many
species should go into the mixture I'm
going to answer this second question for
you now it's two because this is the by
portrait data that I am presenting but
it still remains a question and so we
looked at how what the optimal seeding
rates were using this response surface
design essentially it's a grid on the
x-axis you see the percentage of
standard seeding rates for one species
space work on there on the y-axis you
see a different species so this kind of
design allows us to parse out inter and
intra specific competition uh so it it
comes across it's more powerful so for
this
eight different seating rates of
monoculture so he goes from 40% of the
standard seating rate all the way up to
120 percent of the standard seating rate
which is this for the other species too
we do it for all the mono cultures and
then for the bike quarters what we do is
we also plant at eight different species
so here we have 20 percent sorghum
twenty percent the standard seeding rate
of millet 40 percent sorghum 20 percent
millet how does how does changing these
ratios change the outcome and so there
are six different bipolar combinations
with four species so we have the
original eight different seeding rates
for the monoculture 32 eight times six
forty eight so we have a lot of
different plots what we did how we
planted this happened a summer of 2014
and musgrave what we did is we borrowed
a cone cedar drill from the plant
breeding
we got the adventure and drive it around
and we seeded be small plots about eight
square meters and we had applied to the
field about how I recommended rate of
nitrogen for storage MCG and grass so
we're splitting the fertility evenly
between the leggings and the grasses the
over for life more grasses would show up
if we under fertilize I don't know
everything would look bad so we uh after
about 50 days we all harvested we took 2
meter quadrats clipped all that biomass
off separated Robin weed species and we
also collected density and so biomass
and density are the important things to
remember going into this next slide so
this is the bio mass density
relationship so as you increase density
of a species as you add more plants to a
place you're going to increase the yield
up until a point where you're not going
to increase the yield
your per plant wait it's gonna get
smaller and so what we did is we took
yield we have the biomass data so we
plugged it in there say the biomass the
millet we also have the density of milho
which is Nm and so we plug in the BA the
density for Nm and then we were able to
solve for a naught which is the weight
of a militant without other militants
around it and also for I which has this
measure of interest is the big
competition and so bitter is in 1983
said if you add other species this
assumption this relationship still holds
and so with additional species we just
added this extra term into the equation
so I is is the measure of interspecific
competition and well I should say NS is
the density for the sorghum so let's go
through this I don't know I find this
stuff really heavy so it's helpful for
me to go through it multiple times so
here we have this bio mass density
relationship and I've just given you
some numbers to do it so I am the intro
specific competition coefficient is
point one and then if we were to say
increased point one to point five we see
the shape of this curve changes quite
dramatically it's reaching that
asymptote much faster it's a sharper
curve now we're to add his second
species right this is only the mono
quarters we have a second species we see
that the curve changes even more with
this addition so the I am is back to the
the first petal set at that one but then
we have this extra term is and the NS
and so the shape it has changed and
that's due to the interspecific
competition
so real-life data we did this for all
the by cultures I'm only going to show
you a couple of them so this is the
millet sorghum steed and grass what we
have on the x-axis is millet density
then we have millet biomass on the
y-axis the blue circles are the
monocultures of the millet
the green squares are the millet biomass
wind sort when it's in a millet sorghum
by culture and so this this curve is fit
with the equation that I showed you
before and then this dotted curve that's
a we use the average density of the
sorghum when it's in the by portrayer
with millet we use that for the NS term
and we are able to see that the shape of
the curve changes quite a lot indicating
that there's high interspecific
competition when you add sorghum to
millet you're gonna reduce that millet
biomass and how much you might wonder
well then in this next graph I have
sorghum density on the x-axis still
millet biomass on the y-axis the wind
Milutin monoculture those are the blue
dots you see the yield the clients quite
a lot as you increase the density of the
sorghum Sudan grass but this is just one
side of the story
now always two sides to a story so what
happens with this sorghum when millet is
added to it if weird think about that
it's not really affected at all so when
these when these two curves match up
there's less interspecific competition
happening and we see that also with this
fourth graph here with millet density
you can add Miller density it's not
really affecting the sorghum Sudan grass
biomass
so this is same crash setup as before
but now it's really and sunshine
together we can see the differences
between these two curves there's slight
you know millet slightly affected
somewhat affected by this in him and son
hemp is also slightly affected by the
millet so after putting the biomass the
density and solving for the competition
coefficient but we got royalties
competition coefficients and what what
do these numbers mean how do you relate
them to one another so one way this is
done is with their relative competitive
ability G taking this intraspecific
competition coefficient and dividing it
by the interspecific competition
coefficient so how this reads is you
have millet millet with sorghum millet
with Sun heavily with help you so this
basically says it takes point three
seven sorghum plants to make up a millet
plant so when the RC is less than one
eye you have greater interest specific
competition right your denominators
larger there's like laughing numbers I'm
trying at you and we're trying to find
patterns within them what's happening
across these six different by quarters
so if we what I did was just separated
out and I went through and I said which
ones bigger inter intra inter intra and
some patterns did emerge we see with
sorghum Sudan grass intraspecific
competition was always greater than
interspecific competition and then with
khaki is like a whole different story
interspecific competition was greater if
you go out to a field and you you look
at the fields you can kind of get you're
like wow it's copy you planted
State New York it probably isn't growing
as well as the story against you Darren
grass so the other jefes PC is Miller
and send him there a bit of a mixed bag
right and there are two sides to every
story so how do you weigh both sides of
the story how do you figure out you know
I had it with what the true story is
what the ultimate story is you can just
multiply the relative competition
coefficients together and you get the
nice differentiation index so if nice
differentiate index is above 1 then
retrace partitioning is occurring
because the interest is overall for both
of the species both sides of the story
intraspecific competition is greater
than interspecific competition so this
means it's better to you know have
different plant with different species
maximize that resource partitioning get
a more resources so any that is as I
multiplied the RCS I I got the ndis
I put them in chronological order and
this other pattern emerged and I say
it's so exciting Lee because I was so
pumped to know Bible is like see
something come out of this is that the
Miller plan throw it we're in the top
three so if they have a the highest NDI
so that tells me something about millet
millet plants and like they're good
partners sort of saying good partner
plant so results today relative
competitive ability going from high to
low sir again Sudan grass sunhemp millet
followed by copy then the mixtures with
the greatest complementarity contains
millet that's great and then
the third thing overall just in general
is that want people to use these kinds
of findings to recommend seeding rates
they can maximize productivity of their
mixture and perhaps and I haven't done
it yet
because they the economics might tell
whole different side of the story but
perhaps this could reduce the cost
barrier right if we improve the
precision of these mixtures so the
second question I'm going to ask is
what are the effects of crop diversity
over time movies did for this experiment
first in background this experiment was
funded by an organic research extension
initiative Thank You grant and so we're
looking at organic managed systems and
the reason this is important is because
44% of certified organic producers are
in the Northeast and New York has the
most of all we're the largest producer
of milk organic milk in the Northeast
you know and the other competitors are
Texas and California right they're
operating at a whole different magnitude
of skill but since 2014 the number of
certified organic firms in New York has
doubled happening right now so in the
Northeast in the face of extreme weather
events farmers are having some trouble
meeting the Pastoral rule which requires
that organic herds be out on pasture for
90 days 90 days of the growing season
and so we think that farmers could
supplement their production with
planting crops by planting some annuals
be able to take stem that growing season
and so this is where we're
operationalizing resilience how the
resilience is an abstract term it's
great but how does it actually work in
real life there here we went
cropping systems that absorb risk so
we're going to look at different levels
of crop diversity and then we also want
to be able to adapt to change so we're
going to look at two different cropping
systems perennial and annual and this
would allow the farmer to pivot if
something should happen in their
perennial field stay the summer slump
what could they do to feed their cows
now and then the third one which I'm not
talking about at all is
restoring production so what external
factors are out there does the farmer
have access to capital can they get a
loan from a bank that would help them do
these practices are they getting
disaster payments so what we did is we
looked at four different levels of
diversity so first the low diversity
level one specie is one variety then we
looked at the con specific diversity so
you still had one species but instead we
have four different varieties
what we tried to do is max out the
variety of those varieties so say for
all fawful we chose different
characteristics one of them was crown
rooting one of them was branch rooted
one of them had potato leaf hopper
resistance all of them claim to have
like the best forage quality uh but
those are the characters and we tried to
look for different seed sellers to to
also max on that diversity in case
they're developing lines from the same
stock and so then for the high level of
diversity so that sorry so that was con
specific one species four varieties then
for the hetero specific we had four
different species each had one variety
and then for the high level we have four
species four different varieties and we
really tried although we tried to match
variety out we did try for similar
winter dormancy we want our experiments
to survive and we did try and line up
maturity because that's a big thing if
you have multiple species but then
you're gonna get an optimal forage
quality from that so then we have G
different cropping systems and alfalfa
alfalfa based perennial system and then
alfalfa orchard grass Timothy and white
clover and then a double Kraft annual
system so winter annuals I predict a
tree to Gale cereal rye winter pea red
clover and the summer annuals had CD
grass seed and grass pearl millet
sorghum Sudan grass and rye grass the
other and this experiment took place in
our beloved must gray of farms in rora
but it also happened on other research
firms we were working with Heather Derby
up in Vermont and a rich Smith in New
Hampshire in library and we and you can
imagine all these sites are quite
different right it would like you'll
have cooler climates different time is
different whether a different soil and
so there are a lot of differences when
you think about Oh planting date
harvesting date how much fertilizer to
apply so what we decided to do was to
manage each site independently but
really get on the same track following
the same protocols going through the
same process and the decision-making the
how you know like what are choose where
for management so we established this
experiment in the summer of 2016
randomized complete block design with
four to five replications per site and
going into the management a little more
detail we manage each cropping system by
we manage the two cropping systems
differently and we manage each cropping
system at the set by the needs of the
low diversity treatment so this is a
more conservative approach because
you're adding diversity you're really
making it more difficult to see positive
results when you ride diversity so if we
see good things happening front or
should be normative uh yes
so we also followed fertilizer
recommendations made by seasonal soil
test so each site had a different
phosphorous extraction rate and so we
all send things a grow one baby which
wonder what crops we were going and then
we followed what they recommended for
fertilizer we were harvesting we site
similar thresholds for the harvest so al
fossil was harvest
Stage two when there were one to two
buds per node triticale was that swollen
foot stage seed and grass when it was
about three feet high great so this
figure was developed by Chris poser and
I really like it because they kind of
mops out what the potential is so can
you guys I think they're writing small
so we have months at the the bottom and
these blue bars indicate winter annuals
yellow is summer and Wilson these black
square sir or when we think we could
take a harvest so these are potential
harvest scenarios the annuals maybe we
only got one color for this summer
annuals but perhaps I'm going to get two
you cut and then for the perennials
there are a whole myriad of options we
could do we were aiming to take three
cuts in the first year we only got two
cuts and this past year growing season
2018 we got it we got four cuts so that
was pretty you know this sort of shows
the flexibility that the difference I
have is to like what they're going to do
and and why they might do it so some
hypotheses for these the animal system
will be more productive than the
perennial system and that productivity
and stability yield stability will be
greater in more diverse treatments here
we have this cool photo of just a
traditional monoculture and then the
higher the mixture of those four species
and you can visually see the difference
there
so I'm just really gonna tell you about
results not from this most recent
growing few things I do not yet have
that data but from the growing season
before so 2017 2017 we have a cumulative
growing degree days
New York's a little bit warmer than
everyone the other two sites and then we
have cumulative precipitation as you
might remember mm and I will never
forget it
2017 was a very wet here it was hard for
us also to establish uh Vermont had a
little bit of a dryer season so data
collecting for this experiment and some
analyses that we're doing crop biomass
kneebar Moss will look at weed
communities forage quality we'll look at
the economics in a partial budget
analysis are they work that's happening
is we're looking at soil health
differences in soil microbial and then
also so that's with woody who the grad
student with mine and then also I had a
student to her honors thesis just this
past year with disease incidence and
severity in these plots so we're really
kind of fill out this information here
so basically is some results I did a
linear mixed model where I sum the crop
biomass up over the year so total crop
biomass and all for each treatment in
each system these location system
diversity and their interactions as
fixed effects and we did see a
significant interaction between location
and system and also significance in a
the different diversity as we see here
in this graph so this is the total crop
biomass and we see that the hetero on
high is he's higher more
first mixtures produce more biomass and
I think this was largely because alfalfa
didn't really like all this wet weather
and so when you added grasses to it the
grasses or Geograph in the Timothy we're
much more tolerant could produce a lot
more biomass so I think that's what's
driving the differences here but in this
past year I looked a lot different you
know y'all saw tha made a comeback
so 2017 the results between location and
cropping system New Hampshire and New
York the annuals cropping system
produced more biomass than the
perennials in Vermont we didn't see a
difference perhaps that was because
Vermont was a little drier also there is
likely a knowledge factor I think
Heather has had a lot of experience
growing alfalfa whereas I had not so a
measure of stability so one measure of
stability is the coefficient of
variation and so this is a measure of
dispersal you know where the yield
similar were they were they quite
different into the standard deviation
and divided by the means for those
treatments and these are just the
averages across all the different sites
and they're not statistically different
see that uh but in general the lower the
lower this to be the more stable the
crops yield and so we see that
perennials have numerically lower cv
than the annuals and we also see that
the high diversity treatments had a
lower cv well we also know that yeah
hello Laura
Stevie yes that's all I want to say so
results to date the annuals didn't look
to be more productive than their
perennials more diverse treatments were
more productive for the 2018 growing
season
Yale father made this huge bounce back I
was really excited about an accident
wasn't sure if either of us were going
to make it we were able to get two cuts
of those summer annuals and we got four
cuts for the perennials we're going to
take
one last harvest the winter annuals and
one more cutted they're perennials and
then that'll be it for this experiment
and my fieldwork so I know I don't have
a ton of time left but I want to talk
about this third question science
science doesn't happen in a vacuum and
the context who are going to use crop
diversification strategy and and why
they're going to use them that's really
important I think to consider and to
keep in mind as I as I do this other
research so briefly this state of dairy
farms I collected these headlines and of
course you know I tell people I'm gonna
do interviews with dairy farmers and
everybody like this me down and looks me
straight in the eye and they say you
know it's a really terrible time for
dairy farmers right now and I get by and
it looks really hard to be a dairy
farmer so you have all kinds of
headlines farmers are managing for their
margins anytime they can make a couple
cents extra that's what they're doing
we've seen a spate of bankruptcies New
York being one of the larger ones and so
this is some I just grabbed Diaz from
Winston at all these are dairy farmer
and I know their place
these are dairy farmers in the Northeast
so before in the 1960s we had about
110,000 and now in 2000 it's about
20,000 dairy farmers good so this is the
milk the herd size so the number of
milking cows per thousand heads we've
gone from 3
thousand it's declined we have less cows
and before what they are making more
milk and this is to me an astonishing
idea let since in 1960s you've gone from
on average say eight thousand thousand
yeah eight thousand pounds per year all
the way up to you about eighteen
thousand pounds per year so it's
incredible advancement when I I think
more specifically when am I trying to do
with this body of work I'm interested in
what former characteristics influence
the adoption of crop diversification
practices I'm interested in how a
farmer's social network how that
influences adoption and more generally
how farmers conceptualize resilience
because my idea of what resilience is is
probably quite different from from
somebody else's definition of resilience
but I'm gonna deal with this here's my
plan and this link I haven't really been
done yet so it's still very much but
it's a pretty solid plan I'm gonna say
that much I haven't done it yet but I
think if the producer okay I'm looking
at this Western production region which
is a big milk production region in the
state of New York it goes here so it's
surrounding counties counties that are
also some facing similar weather events
as I am with my eye fields I'm gonna
talk to you about I'm gonna try and talk
to 50 farmers a organic and conventional
management commercially managed farmers
across a range of herd sizes and these
interviews will take I would say about
an hour each I've been a long time
developing this interview guide and rich
fish knows from the beginning of draft
one and now I think it's like draft
twenty something
then we have three components it's
basically general firm questions how
many acres do you have are you supported
by an all farm income how much land do
you rent versus owned where do you sell
your milk to and then also have cropping
systems questions this is where the bulk
of it is because this is where my
research interests lie so what is your
typical crop rotation in the past five
years have you had significant yield
loss on your fields really trying to
understand what the farmer is going
through and how they consider their
cropping systems so ultimately I ask
about the awareness perception the
extent of adoption if they've started to
adopt or considering adopting a practice
motivations and barriers for these
different crop diversification practices
and a couple of extra ones thrown in
because I think might be helpful to
enhance the resilience so if they have
reduced tillage they have tile drainage
yeah and then finally I am asking
farmers about their networks so this is
more like a survey portion of the
interview before the interview is like a
conversation and I'm talking to them and
then this is this reads like a survey
and farmers can check you know what
events have they attended what
organizations do they belong to what
resources do they access when they're
looking for different kinds of crop
diversification information you know who
do they turn to for advice
so far I've and I've done a few
interviews so far every farmer has told
me they talk to their local Extension
agent
when asked when looking when seeking
advice which i think is a really
important idea to not forget uh so I
have some hypotheses on this in general
I'm talking to organic and conventional
days I think there's a lot that can be
said values judgments the different
actors in these two spaces
I think the first equation I'll see a
more profit of rectification practices
in the organic managed system in part
because there's a regulation by requires
that the farms farmers a gooda pasture
where their herd and maybe it was so
unconventional what this means what this
means is that there's probably different
adoption pathways for adoption of these
practices you would use different
language would interact with different
groups if you wanted to get these ideas
diffused so another idea that I have is
do you measure aspects of resilience and
these are the three components I
introduced earlier the absorptive
adaptive restorative I've just listed
some of the things that I'm asking out
now so this is sort of a conceptual idea
in the work so if you have higher soil
organic matter and you might be able to
absorb more risk answer and if you have
seen greater yield stability you know
less yield loss perhaps that's a greater
example of having resilience or a more
resilient cropping system
so progress so far on this project I I
did five pilot interviews during the
summer three with conventional farmers -
with organic farmers and every time it
was like every time I talked to somebody
new I think oh here's a better way to
organize this you know like here's how
the flow could improve I've added new
questions as they have come up change
wording for things so it's a really
iterative process and just you know yeah
it's a it's a great learning process and
I'm going to continue to do the
interviews this winter and next spring
so to circle back around to what I
talked about in the beginning understand
crop different crop diversification as a
strategy to enhance resilience I asked
how can inter crop mixtures be optimized
for biomass production we can design
mixtures that maximize complementarity
using these competition models I see
people talking about digital a core
precision I like and I got very you know
that's where I see this fitting and it's
a really data intensive effort then what
are the effects of crop diversity over
time we need to study this and design
experiments that allow us to understand
some of these benefits that we're not
going to see for a while or may not see
for a while right you can't plan an
extreme weather event all right guess
yep you can't
and then finally who's going to use this
strategy and why and so at different
farms likely have different adoption
pathways who people are engaging with so
they finish this up but I'd like to
think this whole listing people by word
of like honestly you couldn't have done
it without you and I appreciate all the
conversations that we've had at this
time and a big thank you to my lab
family guys are awesome
yes so thank you
[Applause]
one one question is professor on that
first experiment with the intercom
position yeah what kind of note was it
and it was supposed to be used by what
species was it adapted our read it was a
wonder leaf pearl millet we got it from
Kings Agra seed and so they've been
selling this kind of millet farmers in
Pennsylvania in New York so I imagine it
was adopted yeah
honey thank you great great all the work
I really liked how you the rigorous
mechanistic question that you try to ask
in your your first section I was
wondering whether you could shoot from
the hip and say what were the reasons
that made millets are such a good
mixture buddy did you did you consider
measuring route activity distribution or
light intersection or or any other
traits that would identify what it makes
such a good oh yeah that's a great
question and I love the term really as a
planting buddy I spent days of my wife's
out in the fields with a point sensor in
a white bar and it's really tough to
take that kind of light interception but
just shoot for the hip
I think millet is a good planting buddy
because it's very plastic in terms side
it's pretty adaptable it it sees it I'm
going to answer it for more flies this
plant a little bit it sees the plant and
it says I know what your strengths and
weaknesses are and I can sort of adapt
to this so that's how I think about it
but I haven't taken any mechanistic
stuff and the data with the white
interception didn't work out I haven't
looked at what can you really recommend
to a farmer this time and and one of the
questions that always kind of comes up
it is you have this location interaction
and probably location is weather as well
whether soil and all that and and so and
I think that's always the challenge that
we have in making recommendations
there's other factors that come into it
for example maybe you're feels did not
I received manure and on these farms
they would have received manure would
have put the competitive ability of say
a millipede changed if there was during
the environment
so are you at this point in time
comfortable standing up in firm of in
front of a crowd of farmers and say
these are some of the conclusions that I
can draw from my research and I can be
pretty assured that this will work out
yeah that's a great question so if I
were to stand up in front of a group of
farmers I would say millets three times
cheaper than any of the other stood then
I use all right I think the economics of
this situation even though you know like
agronomically that's not movie just
talked about but I think economically
that's a pretty pressing concern and
then planting alfalfa with grasses seem
to be a great way to ensure more biomass
and I think farmers in New York tend to
do that yeah but but I think crafty
versification will I think we'd be in a
very scary place that there were
prescriptions of yeah I don't think
these solutions are prescriptive I think
the ability to create this base for the
farmer to find out what exactly works
for their farm I think that's the way to
go about it
yeah yeah so my plan is within this
western region within these counties so
what I would do is ask the County
Extension agents first my advice and I
how I would try and get a more even
number cuz it's not I won't be able to
not collecting a quantitative data on
that I can it will be all nonparametric
it won't be a normal sample site so what
I can do is say oh extension agent do
you have some large farmers some small
farmer is some some some these farmers
some of those farmers and generate a
list from that and try and ask for as
great a variety as possible really early
on and then using a snowball sampling
method which i think is cool name for a
sampling method if you get like a really
diverse bottom where's it was like
across the range of slices and then you
ask those farmers hey can you recommend
somebody that's that's not like you to
farm and you can sort of percolate those
differences so I think we're out of time
but thank you guys again
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu